benvenuti nello show più sopravvalutato
di sempre già dopo la prima puntata si
prima di iniziare io i miei maglioni da
nonno vorremmo dirvi due cose vi
ringrazio tantissimo per l'enorme
accoglienza nel video precedente ma non
dovevate no davvero non dovevate adesso
mi sono montato la testa essendo proprio
il bisogno urgente di andare a
pomeriggio 5 farmi intervistare da
barbara no quello che voglio dire che il
primo mostarde stato fortunato
paraculato è fortunato non parlerò sono
di film e non parlerò solo di film
gruppi ho voluto iniziare in quel modo
lì per facilitarvi la transizione da
recensioni anno recensioni e quindi
recitare in un romanzo criminale perché
il nome di tutto ciò che è sacro nella
televisione non sento mai parlare di
romanzo criminale non i film di michele
placido quello dove fanno esplodere la
stazione di bologna al computer ma la
serie andata in onda su sky tratto
dall'omonimo libro di giancarlo de
cataldo che vi invito a leggere palla
della banda della magliana storica banda
che negli anni 80 ha cercato di
conquistare roma è qualcosa di assurdo
quanto è bella serie però mi raccomando
ricordatevi che tutto questo non lo sto
dicendo io che non sono in genere non so
recitare non so produrre non so fare il
tecnico della fotografia infatti non so
manco mettere luci giuste nei miei video
non ho molto spazio in cui lavorare
ragazzi è quindi riuscita a prendere
un'opinione personale per quella che è
senza rompere le palle nei commenti
fantastico non vi voglio addormentare
con i dettagli della trama
anche perché tutto quello che direi
potrebbe essere usato contro di voi
sotto forma di spoiler
voglio solo cercare di spiegarvi perché
secondo me è una delle pochissime parola
chiave pochissime sedi italiane decenti
beh prima di tutto non c'è gabriel garko
nel cast è quello secondo me è già un
passo avanti
sto scherzando signor garko lei è un
uomo straordinario arrivo da letta un
secondino prima di tutto
sia di soli ma avete presente quei film
o quelle serie che ambientano la loro
storia in un luogo che il budget non può
coprire tipo che devono ambientarlo in
un pianeta lontano lontano e poi si vede
lontano 2 km che le hanno aumentato nel
giardino dietro casa loro con ancora il
barbone ii che lo stanno svegliando
previsti poi levare dal set
ecco soli ma non è così basta guardare
la prima puntata per capire che ci
troviamo di fronte a un mostro sembra
veramente di essere catapultati nella
roma di fine anni settanta vestiti auto
armi telefoni e tanti piccoli dettagli
che messi nella posizione giusta ti
riescono a catapultare in una finzione
che tanto finzione non è alla fine la
regia invece di quelle che preferisco io
mettiamo in chiaro una cosa io adoro le
inquadrature ricercate alla breaking bad
quelli che rappresentano un qualcosa
quelli che raccontano una piccola storia
nella storia così come una di quelle
prostitute d'alto borgo nei bordelli di
parigi anni 40 il romanzo criminale è
l'opposto e di quelle regie sporche
movimentate che ti fa soltanto vedere
quello che accade senza metterci troppa
bocca quasi come una di quelle
prostitute che si trovano ora in corso
massimo e che ogni volta mi minacciano
una borsetta alla di sci per intenderci
o the bourne identity solo che cazzo
league per capire una scena d'azione
devi avere veramente qualche nevrosi
celebrare perché se non stai capendo chi
colpisce chi e dulcis in fundo gli
attori loro sono l'anello che tiene
legato tutto il lavoro
semplicemente sono credibili neanche per
mezzo secondo pensato che stessero
recitando in particolare i quattro
protagonisti il libanese francesco
montanari il dandi alessandro roja il
commissario scialoja marco bocci è il
mio preferito il freddo interpretato
dall improponibile nome di vinicio
marchioni
ed è questo il punto su cui mi vorrei
soffermare la recitazione
io personalmente non so recitare mai a
meno che recitare non voglia dire
riprodurre con i lego la scena di stupro
di arancia
carica ci ho provato più volte ma non fa
per me e non mi va di scopare con un
produttore per avere una parte quindi
che tra l'altro quando sono davanti alle
telecamera posso dire qualsiasi cagata è
farla sembrare vera ma quando sto
recitando in un set di una produzione
piccolo grande che sia
e c'è qualcuno dietro che sta guardando
microfonisti luci cose mi prende il
panico e non riesco a dire neanche le
frasi più semplice tesoro vai ad
apparecchiare valere amore vado ad
apparecchiare però da spettatore riesce
a capire se uno sta recitando bene o se
un cane di quelli che manca una pallina
di riporta quando gliela tiri ed è qui
che secondo me il romanzo criminale si
alza di molteplici spanne sopra la
concorrenza è fottutamente e credibile i
dialoghi sono brevi e diretti non ci
sono quei monologhi che nella vita di
tutti i giorni nessuno mai direbbe non
le odiate quelle cose nei telefilm
italiani scene dove vorrà prendere il
pane manco fosse laureto tenga il resto
grazie mille grazie mille uomo del pane
gli altri panettieri non sono così
gentili con le genti che li vengono a
trovare le porterò un presente dalla mia
fattoria non vuoi sto cazzo di rapha lo
sa già che noi non abbiamo il telefilm
noi abbiamo gli sceneggiati e le fiction
poi chiamarli come voi tanto sempre
merda rimangono ok
nel video scorso mi avete accusato di
sparare contro la croce rossa ed è vero
quindi cercherò di non essere troppo
stronzo quando guardo una puntata di
squadra antimafia il mio corpo vomita le
sue stesse interiora che se tutte le
leggi hanno una sceneggiatura migliore
di quella questo è quello che succede
nei primi 5 minuti della prima ondata di
squadra antimafia un'auto esplode per un
attentato detto sono tutti vivi o un abu
dhabi carabinieri spiegatemi come posso
prendere su
meglio una serie in cui protagonisti
mirano con la pistola in questo punto
qua fermo polizia non stai tenendo in
mano la telecamera e tu non sei un cazzo
di treppiede o magari sono ignorante io
e se c'è qualche amico dell'arma che mi
segue magari mi può venire a dire se
effettivamente si tiene in queste
braccia così tese che se spari un colpo
ts fuori l'osso dal gomito
va benissimo ma a me va bene lì non sono
dell'arma quindi non so 1 semi di gente
che mi aveva quasi preso era distretto
di polizia
finché poi non hanno voluto sostituire
attori quasi capaci come ricky memphis e
giorgio pasotti e giorgio tirabassi con
bambole di pezza max giusti
davvero c'è lui è credibile come
poliziotto come io sono credibili da
imperatore cinese medievale e tutto
questo sarebbe ancora ancora passabile 6
dialoghi non fossero quanto di più finto
io abbia mai sentito in vita mia
la maggior parte delle volte io non sto
guardando attori recitare io sto
guardando dei pupazzi enormi imbottiti
di belle facce e nient'altro ed è qui
che ritorna garko ma ciao volevo
chiederti vento cazzo cc fuori ogni due
secondi ogni volta che guarda la tv tu
sei l'esempio lampante dell'attore
belloccio e con una mandibola
stranamente attraente squadrate perfetta
come se avessi una cassettina di mogano
infilata in bocca che per ora riesce a
di due parole giuste di fila cavolo ero
più convincente io a 5 anni quando
dicevo ai miei genitori si mamma ho
fatto i compiti
sì sì a 5 anni aveva una voce da bambina
ma bene il peccato e la vergogna
il sangue la rosa l'onore e il rispetto
la noia e la rottura di [ __ ]
no non c'è
strano però mai spezziamo una lancia
almeno a favore di manuela arcuri che
riesce egregiamente nel ruolo di meno
naturale possibile
male al fattore tette quindi ma questi
sceneggiati sono fatti per un motivo
solo per mettere qualcosa in sottofondo
alle casalinghe in provincia di torino
mentre stira non è capito
i mariti a lavoro non conosco nessuno
della mia vita che guardi queste cose ci
sono solo io nella mia stanzetta al buio
mentre bevo un bicchiere di tisana al
finocchio che ruba il tempo al porno per
guardarmi queste cose farci un video ma
romanzo criminale no lui è l'unica cosa
che sono riuscito a tornare dall'inizio
alla fine senza la voglia di conficcare
una martina dell'occhio dopo dieci
minuti sono due stagioni in cui riesce a
farti piacere le storie di ogni suo
personaggio buono cattivo che sia a
tralasciando poi il discorso dell è
giusto romanizzare e tifare per
personaggi negativi realmente esistiti è
un'ottima domanda è giusto compatire ad
appassionarsi per le storie di quelli
che sono realmente i vendicativi tutti
hanno parlato per anni per esempio dave
joker de il cavaliere oscuro ma quella è
finzione
la banda della magliana invece è
realmente esistita e neanche troppi anni
fa è giusto stare dalla parte della
banda anche solo se in tv io non lo so
credo sia l'empatia del momento e il
grande lavoro di sceneggiatura non ho
mai sentito nessuno che durante salvate
il soldato ryan e inizia a urlare queste
moralmente sbagliato preferiscono ucciso
nella scena sette inquadratura due aveva
una famiglia è il giusto marani
mariolini e tu non puoi fare gli
americani l'hanno ucciso tu hai comunque
delle sensazioni per personaggi che
rappresentano la realtà non alla realtà
stessa quindi secondo me sì è giusto
prendersi bene per una storia anche se
una parte di storia nera secondo voi
cos'è che diceva già battiston e sugli
attori cani
avete sentito
cani siete solo cani o parti sto
alquanto sei cattivo gioco
diciamo cacciare più bello del mondo
chimica il bello del mondo di andiamo
non provino